how to succeed in business or with
brunettes or blondes they're all
important missions wouldn't you agree
well here's one way to tackle a brunette
problem see what you think
first of all be late that'll show her
you're a busy important person but
you're not too interested in her play
hard to get
after all you're worth waiting for this
will make a great first impression
then laugh at all
apologize oh come on don't be a square
okay now the timer show her but a sense
of humor you had by holding her coat
just a little bit too high that's right
next be masterful protective grasper arm
firmly and steer down those steps to the
car she can see that you're the
aggressive masculine type what are you
doing opening the door you'll spoil your
image oh that's better
sure treater is an equal women like that
besides if you're late there's no sense
wasting time on things she can do for
herself let's face it sometimes it's
just not enough time for good manners
right doors afford a continued supply of
chances to make an impression on your
companion don't pass one up it's always
good for a laugh and an opportunity to
show off your leadership qualities how
by leading the way going first naturally
that's the boy keep leading the way good
naval officers always lead their men or
their women in this case when you get to
your table sit down immediately shows
your relaxed
help with her called well you're helped
her on with it besides it's her cold she
should have checked it anyway
oh yes make sure you're seated so you
can see what's going on too makes for a
much more interesting evening
now here's perfect opportunity to
demonstrate your independence
remain seated after all it's not during
working hours and you are doing him a
favor by presenting your date to him on
the other hand she should be impressed
by meeting a senior officer hmm no
question about this young lady will be
grateful for such a lovely evening with
a charming person like you that's one
approach to the problem of how to
succeed with brunettes suppose we
consider another way and see what you
think
how about starting by being on time not
just for a date but for any social
engagements or business appointment this
indicates you are a dependable
businesslike person that the appointment
means something to you and let's face it
a good looking girl isn't going to wait
around too long for anybody too many
young men on the prowl make it easy for
her to slip into her coat hold it at the
right height that's being thoughtful
watch the hair if you must
you're going to lose points
no you don't grab her arm you offer
assistance if she needs it or wants it
she'll take your hand or perhaps your
arm
but once the need for assistance is
passed she'll give it back to you so
don't be surprised yes doors do offer an
excellent chance to make a good
impression it's a way to show you
respect for ladies or your seniors for
that matter thoughtfulness making things
easier for someone else this is at the
heart of good manners and in the heart
of every gentleman besides it's the way
to succeed with brunettes ladies first
it's an old saying but a good one 90% of
the time of course if you're entering a
restaurant or something comparable and
there's no met roadie or hostess to lead
you to a table then you would lead the
way and select the table she'll expect
you to help her loft with her coat and
arrange it over the back of her chair so
it's not all over the floor no she
shouldn't have checked it it is common
practice for a lady to wear her coat to
the table although if she indicates a
preference for checking it that's fine
too there she has an excellent view of
the room good thinking you want her to
have a good time and being able to see
what's going on will be had of the fun
if you have a visitor and you probably
will when you have a companion like that
stand to show your respect for a senior
or a lady this isn't just military
etiquette it's being a gentleman and you
present a man even if it's the Admiral
himself to Eleni respect again it's his
pleasure to meet her in this case there
isn't much doubt about it check the menu
with your date and if you have any
knowledge about the specialties of the
house or know particularly good dishes
let her in on it but once you have both
decided you do the order
well that's another approach to how to
succeed with brunettes looks like a
winner
wouldn't you say let's take another
typical situation going to the theater
you know there seems to be something
wrong here ah that's it
he's walking on the wrong side wonder
what his next move will be a taxi that
means a door and that means yes sir this
fellow's a born leader
one thing you could say he's consistent
isn't he wait a minute what's happening
here the girl out first well I guess he
boxed himself in by getting into the
taxi first too bad but he'll make it up
that's right
pick the seats you want
whoo loudly sir
sorry about that now settle down and
enjoy the movie nothing like a little
snack to add to the fun and your
neighbors will love you what do you say
we go through this situation again the
right way the way that's successful with
brunettes that's more like it
you walk on the curbside at all times or
on her left and when you part company or
meet a lady a salute is the proper
greeting or farewell it's the same thing
as tipping your hat when you're in
civilian clothes
believe me the brunette is impressed
that's right ladies first it's a good
rule most of the time and logical if you
consider that the reason is to make
things easier for the lady
now here's one of those situations where
the lady doesn't go first the reason you
go first
is to make things easier for her to open
the door and a sister in getting out of
the automobile it makes sense just as
most gentlemanly traditions do right
it's her decision on where to sit
not yours if you want to make a good
impression be considerate of the other
person adjust your preferences to Hertz
and if you feel you must nibble on
something during the show at least do it
quietly out of consideration for your
neighbors well you are squared away on
how to succeed in restaurants and
theatres let's take another situation a
small gathering in a home or officer's
club oh I have a feeling we're going to
see anything but the right way to do
things
anyway the necessity for making and
acknowledging introductions occurs
frequently it should be done correctly
but I wouldn't bet on it
in this case mrs. brewer I'd like you to
meet Mary Jackson and midshipman
Williams perfect introduction man
presented to lady looks as though he's
going to wring her hand off doesn't it
and who knows what if she wanted to
shake hands or not of course she had no
choice his hand was out quicker than a
waiters in a nightclub oh hello there
wait for these good-looking women the me
Chet Barry this is mr. prend mr. Brandes
is Mary thank you good evening Mary
wha-oh mrs. Charles mrs. rora like to
have you shake hands with a commander
mrs. Charles mr. Roy
oh it's almost unbelievable isn't it
this young man puts bad manners back to
bay first he calls a senior officer mr.
instead of by his rank he still doesn't
get on his feet and he presents the
ladies to the commander instead of vice
versa and I do believe he was going to
ignore the two ladies completely if it
hadn't been for the commander well we'd
better run through the whole thing again
the right way because you do want to be
6
with those brunettes right yeah three
children three children
22 nice shoes mrs. Rohr I'd like you to
meet Mary Jackson and midshipman Brown
how do you do there how do you do mrs.
hearth how do you do jack is in your
husband's battalion oh good evening
commander levy mrs. child's missus roars
miss Jackson this is commander prent how
do you do meet you I believe he was
aboard the constellation when your
husband was mrs. chop that's how you
succeed in being a gentleman and impress
brunettes wait until the lady offers her
head then shake it briefly firm but not
crushing you get on your feet for a lady
or your senior in rank or age as a
matter of fact it's good manners to
acknowledge an introduction to anybody
by rising perfect the senior officer
addressed by his rank you're on your
feet and the man is presented to the
ladies a good way to remember this is to
mention the names of the ladies or
senior officers first in the
introduction in the case of introducing
one person to a group just follow a
simple practice the single person is
introduced to the group if this group
had been larger you would have said this
is commander Prynne then ticked off the
names of each member of the group
mrs. Coleman may I present Miss Emma
Severn how nicely with this tonight how
are you this evening
all right let's consider a more formal
situation the receiving line it looks as
though we're going to get a lesson in
how not to succeed in being a gentleman
let's see how it goes
hi I'm Charlie Williams how you die mrs.
Coughlin represent midshipman Williams
mrs. Kaufman really a nice party glad
you invited in there I'm Arya
nice party see you Jack's dad you say
weren't you on the Salem if my memory
serves me correctly during the Korean
War
yeah hello jack wait he's making points
with the Admiral though but what about
the girl he went through the line
without even thinking about her she may
as well have come along I wouldn't give
him much hope for any success with her
other than that what do you think about
the rest of his behavior more important
still how do you think those people feel
let's take this situation again the
right way you'll note that the young
lady does not hold your arm that is
correct and you walk on her left as you
near the line allow her to move ahead
no handshaking with the aid or escort
however the first person in line may be
the host or hostess at times so if the
hand is offered take it of course that's
a very simple rule just wait until the
other person offers to shake hands
miss Jackson miss Cullen represent miss
Jackie
mr. Jackson see jacket shipment ground
very this is the way to go through a
receiving line if an aide or dance
chairman or some similar person heads up
the line you do not shake hands further
as in all handshaking situations you
wait for ladies and seniors to extend
their hands before you shake hands your
date precedes you in the line as usual
it's ladies first and you move through
the line quickly with no stops for
conversation this just isn't a time or
the place to be talkative your remarks
may be how do you do sir good evening
Admiral or similar brief courteous
comments after the line well let's take
a look here's a beautiful way to succeed
with brunettes at a dance at a party
wherever you may go
leave her to shift for herself
occasionally she'll appreciate you all
the more when you do return sure she
will when you are with her be effectual
present just how much you care for her
she'll love it
if she happens to be an exhibitionist
and for goodness sake don't let anything
or anybody spoil your fun don't get
stuck being a nursemaid for somebody
else's date let him worry about her a
good way to make an impression is to
fold your partner tightly while moving
all over the dance floor she'll love it
wanna dance all night with you shall we
rest for a while
I feel as though I'm coming down to the
cold or something maybe you could take
me home and then there's the right way
to do things make sure your date has a
good time meets and dances with your
friends at other times your place is
with her be considered that's your main
obligation and if another young lady is
left alone for some reason stand by
until her escort appears consideration
for Hubble's kindness this is being a
gentleman
dancing this is good duty no question
about that enjoy but be in good taste
show respect for your date and her
reputation and she will respect you
success with brunettes or blondes or
just about anybody is built upon respect
and being a gentleman is to command
respect how to succeed with brunettes be
a gentleman